génération lully prend forme petit à
petit les acteurs se découvre en
décembre dernier le champ était à
l'honneur hier soir on danse et c'est
dans ce que tu attends du xviie siècle
qu'on appelle la belle danse la danse
baroque
c'est une danse qui vient elle même de
la danse traditionnelle donc c'est avait
là à travers les pins n'est pas si loin
que ça sous l'impulsion musicale n'est
pas si loin que ça de la danse maroc
le cercle celtique c'est isabelle mais
aussi sept danseurs ne la compagnie
black blanc beur font partie du projet
une passerelle entre différentes époques
[Musique]
de toute manière au niveau de la danse à
un partage donc si on partage pas abba
pas d'ouverture et ici il n'y a pas
d'ouverture bon ça c'est fermé sur soi
et puis bah c'est important aussi
d'avoir à cette forme d'ouverture en
fait voilà par rapport aux autres dans
aux autres types de danse plus que deux
mois de préparation avant de révéler
l'opéra des farceurs le public
découvrira l'histoire de jean baptiste
lully à la merise de trappes
[Musique]